a place in the Capital One Cup final at
stake there's frustration in the Chelsea
camp and then this
edan aza the Belgian appears to kick
seventeen-year-old ball boy Charlie
Morgan in the ribs the striker sent off
for the incident for violent conduct
swansea manager was unimpressed
I can understand all frustrations you
know when you are behind and you want we
all try that I've been playing myself
you know the you have 118 in the pulse
but there are things you can never do
Charlie Morgan was suspected of trying
to help Swansea City it earlier tweeted
the king of all ball boys is back making
his final appearance needed for time
wasting his number of Twitter followers
rocketed by thousands after the game
Chelsea's manager says the player and
the ball boy apologized to each other
after the match the boy was coming to
talking with hasar beau they apologized
each other because I said he went into
the dressing room after student they
were talking both and then the boy was
he knows that he was wasting time as I
was a frustrated because he wanted to
get the ball back
so they apologized they know that was a
mistaken that's it reaction to this
latest incident from the footballing
world was Swift Michael Owen tweeting
both the kid and azar were in the wrong
not sure as I tried to hurt him though
he just tried to poke it out of his grip
South Wales police have interviewed the
ball boy in this case and no complaint
has been made but that may not be enough
for the FA which may still want to carry
out its own investigation Chris cutter
Sky News